and we have some sports news out of
afghanistan their female youth national
football team and their families a group
of 80 in total have been granted asylum
by portugal after trying to leave
afghanistan for weeks unsuccessfully the
group has now arrived in lisbon the
taliban have banned girls from playing
any sport and fearing what their lives
might become the team had been moving
between safe houses before being granted
asylum all of the girls aged between 14
and 16 want to become pro football
players in the future
as well as athletes afghan musicians are
also facing oppression under the new
taliban regime afghanistan's only
institute for music has closed down and
its members fear for their safety and
their future their director who is in
exile in australia after leaving the
country in july for medical treatment is
hoping to help
it was a building full of music hope and
optimism 250 students were enrolled at
the national institute of music in kabul
a third of them female a safe place to
practice laugh and discover the world
but the school was constantly under
threat
its director survived a suicide bomb
attack from exile in australia his
defiance is undimmed even as the taliban
have banned music in public
places still i believe that no one can
take the music from the life of a human
being
you can't kill music music is not going
to die
i am an ambassador from the land of hope
these girls sing i stand up against
oppression
[Music]
self-confident and passionate wearing
their national costume a young orchestra
with a female conductor at the podium
one of two that afghanistan's only music
school produced
a sound the taliban does not tolerate
that lack of
knowledge of this beautiful language is
probably based on the ignorance of the
taliban and also
on the narrow
narrow interpretation of the teaching of
holy islam there's not a single islamic
country around the world where music
could have been banned or music is
banned currently
the centerpiece of this kabul music
school is zora the first afghan women's
orchestra it played 47 concerts
worldwide in the last 10 years including
in berlin
the berlin philharmonic orchestra's horn
player welcomed the ensemble's members
on their visit to the capitol
we love playing music
not only because we like to make
beautiful sounds but because we can
express our souls with it and when you
play music you become one with the music
and if you're not allowed to do that
it's such a terrible thing
i just can't even imagine it
but the orchestra has stopped playing
even before the taliban seized power
conductor zarifa adiba could not take
her instrument home it was too dangerous
i don't have viola at home and
i never i never ever practiced viola at
home because
i'm afraid that anyone should know that
i'm playing viola
conductors arifa and her colleague nagin
are now safe in the u.s
all of the other orchestra members are
in hiding in kabul
from on that subject we can speak now to
the hornets we just saw in that report
sarah willis she's a horn player with a
berlin philharmonic and she's also hosts
sarah's music program here on dw sarah
what's gone through your mind with the
news from afghanistan this past month
especially when it comes to music
goodness well just hearing the report
just now and hearing the words of of
sarifa and dr samas i i just have to
think of this wonderful day i spent with
them and how impressed i was with the
bravery of these young girls because
okay they were very young some of them
and maybe the danger wasn't quite
um you know registered yet but they all
knew that what they were doing
could have consequences and they did it
anyway and i just admired them so much
and it's really breaking my heart to
hear these reports now
so as you said you met members of the
women's orchestra zora in berlin when
they were on tour here four years ago
tell us more about that encounter
well i showed them the philharmonie um
they were so impressed with the with the
concert hall and i was i was impressed
how much they knew about classical music
actually which is a a great sign that
they were getting very good training um
not just in the afghan music but also in
general general music training and uh we
had a very fun morning together and then
i accompanied them to their rehearsal in
their concert at the um at the memorial
church the goddess here in in berlin and
there just been that terror um attack on
the chair on the on the christmas market
there and they all went outside and laid
flowers and it was very moving to see to
see them doing something for us and uh
it was just a wonderful happy
music-filled day and they're young girls
you know they're chattering laughing
getting ready for the concerts and
they're so colorful when you see them in
their beautiful clothes that they were
wearing for the concerts and the joy of
music making it's just music just
connects and you could sense this joy
all the way through the concert
you mentioned that they are playing uh
classical western music as well as
afghan
music but classic classical music is
being played all around the world but
what could happen to the country's
musical heritage of afghanistan's
musical heritage when uh with the
government's so anti-music
this is the big question and of course
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future the reports of the last few
weeks are really sad and really worrying
um if it carries on like this then the
musical heritage of afghanistan will
really suffer because it's a whole
generation of music making but also
music teaching that will literally be be
silenced
and
if we are still allowed to hope we are
hoping it may not come to this but
it's not looking good as far as i can
see it at the moment
um and it's it's not only that this
music
needs to be learned that the instruments
that these wonderful traditional afghan
instruments the rhubarb for example and
the sitar and the tabla
they need to be taught and most of this
music isn't written down so it's taught
from you know from generation to
generation and if it's silence now how
are these girls going to pass it down
not even the girls the boys that were
learning it too how are they going to
pass it down to the next generation and
and a world without music a silent world
nobody wants that
and it's not only about music itself
isn't it i mean musical education means
so much more doesn't it
it certainly does it's this this feeling
of creating something together to be to
be expressing your soul um and music
learning music is very good for the
brain we we know that it's very good for
young children for their brain
development and also what was important
in afghanistan at the a a nim
was the um the fact that boys and girls
studied together and they learned about
the interaction together because they've
been separated and they were never
allowed to inter-interact like that so
um
you can see in some of the videos of the
school um they're sitting next to each
other playing together so that's an
important social aspect as well
sarah willis horn player with the berlin
philharmonic orchestra thank you very
much sarah
thank you